let's let's let's let's we can sort of
bring up the the don't say gay lie
the hoax from the democrats the bill in
florida's true intent was to make sure
parents are informed about what's
happening with their kids
the left lied and claimed it was don't
say gay i know we've mentioned it
several times but i think this is you
know relevant to what we're talking
about if if they're using these
manipulations to try and stop
transparency
one of the things in the bill is that
teachers can't discourage children from
talking to their parents
because one of the things these teachers
are doing is telling the kids not to
talk to their parents it just seems like
there's a lot of external pressures on
people to sever themselves from
community family religion etc
ultimately you you add in the the
transhumanist factor or the neural link
and the metaverse and what you end up
with is
in order it feels like in order for
there to be like a metaverse you would
need these things beforehand yeah in
order to get your hands on on kids you
need to break up the family and the
strongest connection
uh pardon me for saying is mothers and
children
and
surrogacy is a massive thing that
totally separates the idea that
mothers carry children and have children
and raise and nurture infants
and so all of it is there's not much
that we're doing that actually
reinforces the family and i know the
family in america has got the weird
connotations of family traditional like
homophobic
if you mention family values all of a
sudden you're saying something anti-gay
um
but it's
it's just really interesting if i was a
predator if i was a nasty predator
predatory pedophile i would absolutely
love the segregation of of children from
families and mothers from children and
disempowering mothers and there's no
greater way to disempower mothers and
actually rob women of all of their
rights and power and vocabulary of all
of their rights as a mother yeah to even
call yourself a mother yeah it's it's
shockingly horrifying to see how this is
going on and then you have school
districts like in florida there's a
couple of cases um i was talking to a
woman january littlejohn the other day
who was suing her school district um
because they started their her daughter
on the road to gender transition and
didn't tell the family so another family
in florida
where
they didn't know that their child was
exploring gender identity at school
until the child tried to kill herself
in the bathroom at the school and then
it turned out that they were keeping
they were having like secret gender
identity meetings and the idea
right that was florida which
precipitated the parental rights bill
right where they clearly need it
you know so you have situation where
educators and administrators think that
it's their job to help children keep
secrets from their parents because all
parents are going to be abusers and they
even said in that one case in florida
well the family is catholic so they're
automatically going to be abusive and
non-understanding and the father was
like uh what
our religion teaches us to love our
children
i kind of just feel like
you know whether it's intentional or not
over the past several decades there's
been a major push for the precursor of
transhumanism i think it's for sure yeah
intentional i find that if we're divided
into subsets of classes in this species
that we have we have the the elite and
the plebeians which is everyone else and
it's really a class of elite whatever
you wanna call them are they they are
family type they are knit units where
they like the children run the business
that the dad ran and they're always in
contact and they're flying on their jets
to see each other and their their kids
know their parents and then you've got
everybody else man and they're just
letting the wild animals graze right now
i just i just kind of realized something
you know i used to make the joke that
the future is going to be everybody with
shaved heads wearing jumpsuits
or giant you know cones over their
bodies so that no one can tell because
of you you know uh um like
harrison bergeron is that what it's
called yeah
harrison bergeron
uh and then i just realized why that's
wrong
because people are going to plug
themselves into the neural linked
metaverse
where you are just a gray blob and
everyone will then just be the same
generic avatar i don't think they would
they will be the same avatar i think
your star
for sure so it'll be the blank slate
ideology and then you have to grind for
your for your outfits and your stuff
here's the interesting thing about it
though
if you take every single human being
and erase their minds or if you do this
you take one million babies
and you put them in the metaverse where
they all start off as genderless you
know jumpsuit wearing little humans and
they grow and develop and then you know
around the time they're 10 or whatever
it's like now choose your gender and
they can just pick i'll tell you this
you would find a massive correlation
between biological sex and internal
digital world gender
so they can so so if you take a kid and
raise them
in you know metaverse
i i would be willing to bet there's like
a 98 chance that kid would be like i'm a
boy or i'm a girl
they would decide it or they would be it
what i'm saying is if you ask if you
take a child a baby and put them in the
metaverse right where they never
experience the real world and they have
no gender then at 12 years old they go
to school you ask them which gender
would you choose they would likely
choose their biological sex the one they
actually are right yeah so even in the
metaverse they'd also really need to
stretch out they'd be like this feels
uncomfortable well their brain is doing
they wouldn't they wouldn't know that
they're trapped in a pod so they
wouldn't even know that they have a body
no
the and and so i mean they probably
would i think if we enter this
transhumanist reality where everyone is
a blank slate and everyone's born this
way
you're gonna it's like you're gonna have
a million babies they're gonna they're
gonna grow up and then you're gonna see
a 98 correlation with biological sex of
the physical world body and the chosen
gender in the metaverse is it overhead
so well i was just going to say look
because i
i'm far too hopeful to think this is the
future for human beings but also
even if you're right there's only going
to be a certain number of people that
can afford to join them the you don't
think the metaverse everybody's got a
cell phone it's only it's only a matter
of time it'll start with the rich people
but then give it 10 years and it's gonna
be a 20 metaverse pass and what about
the people that are religious and are
family connected in countries like india
see uh i actually
i'm working on a tv show um yeah so i
can't say too much but it basically
explores the idea that there are a lot
of people who will not take the neural
link and a lot of people who want it
and what ian mentioned is there's kind
of divergence happening within human
evolution right now where you're going
to have what you said homo cyberneticist
or whatever something like that
homocybernetic versus homo sapien and
you're gonna have a lot of people who
are like this is the real world we love
our family we believe in god it's
interesting because we're now facing the
real prospect of a divergence between
the human species
by choice almost by ideology so
did you read uh em foresters the machine
stops
so basically that's what happens in the
in that it's like a little novella
um and i think he wrote it in like 1914
or something ridiculous like that and
basically there's people in pods and
all of their information comes to them
through this view screen and there's a
machine that they can ask to bring them
food and whatever it is that they need
but this one guy reaches out to his mom
and his the way that he has a mother is
that the machine set her up with this
guy and they had a child and then the
child was taken to like a nursery pod
where it was raised but anyway he
reaches out to his mom and he's like i
would really like to breathe some clean
air they live underground in this thing
oh yeah i saw a movie that was basically
this maybe yeah it was
but it's interesting because in the book
there is this one guy who's like no i'm
not doing this
he was raised in that in that
environment and he comes to it on his
own that he doesn't want to live like
this
and he eventually makes it to the
surface of the earth where he dies from
the poison air but
he tries and
he tries i mean it is kind of a happy
ending because he's like i made it
i see the sun
i see you know well so uh for everybody
listening maybe you can you guys the
audience is always really good at
helping me out with this there's a show
it might be electric dream was it
electric dreams is that what the show
was called
but uh i watch all these different
sci-fi anthology shows it's a kid who
lives in this you know pod where he
plays video games all day and he
interacts with interacts with his mom
over text chat and they just play
platform video games and food is
automatic and then one day his pot
breaks
he has no choice but to go outside where
he thinks the air is toxic but it's not
and then he goes to his mom and he
knocks on the door and she's freaking
out like what is going on why is there a
person here it sounds very similar to
what you were describing but it's you
know yeah i mean i it sounds similar i
think it's i think it's a similar theme
in in literature
i wonder if you're going to have like
humans on mars that are neural linked
humans on mars that aren't humans on
earth that are knurling humans on earth
that aren't and you'll have like four
different species
and then they'll all go to war and one
of them will become the predominant
species
would you do it would you neurolinkian
yeah you would do it yeah
some people are saying it was electric
driving i've been clearing my mind as
practicing meditation where you have no
thought for like ow i can have like no
thought for an hour and the metaverse
can be really important because they're
going to be trying to read your thoughts
mm-hmm so you got to like the end of
ghostbusters were like don't think of
anything he thinks of the marshmallow
man right he sure doesn't think of
anything you need a clear thought or
they're going to be controlling them
so do you think then in this in this
happy
future that we're all looking at that
those in
maybe authoritarian religious countries
will they be less likely
to hook up
i don't know about that it's a great way
to control the population um yeah so
they might just say we'll create our own
isolated introverse
where everyone can you know
it depends on whether you think the
people who run
do you think the people who lead iran
are actually religious or they want
power and control well i think they're
both
because then if if it's just about power
control they'll say whatever they have
to and absolutely would adopt a
metaverse-like system
if they're actually religious they
probably would resist
depends on how religious or how they
interpret their religion oh yeah there
will be religions in the metaverse and
stuff where it's like it becomes a
religion you're the funniest you're the
funniest they'll worship like you know
it would be like golden calf it'd just
be hilarious if we're actually in it
right now and
what i think will happen is some people
will start will they'll start
metaversing government military and then
they'll see it's so powerful to be able
to control the machines with your
thoughts that
even the most religious
zealous will start doing it because it's
either that or die like don't fall
behind on the technology it's a weapon
it can be used as a as a weapon for sure
if we were in it right now i don't think
my children would be so rude
but if you know what i mean you might
not know you know
you just you know maybe maybe uh we're
the remnants of a post-apocalyptic
civilization that destroyed the planet
and purposefully chose to put ourselves
in a matrix so that we can live oh
that's such a road to hell
great a hotel process is
yeah that's a that's a spiral into i do
i don't think we are i i just only
because i have no evidence i don't think
we're not i just don't think we are no i
agree with that but i do think
it really does feel like that's the
direction we're going in you've got
people who
jump from one cause to another you see
what elon musk tweeted yeah i i support
current things the npc meme holding
ukrainian flag with all the other flags
around it
and i'm like that's that's a great point
i'm wondering what what it is that has
created this large group of millions of
people
who are mindless drones
it makes me wonder
what if
well i'll put it this way i think those
people are absolutely going to neural
link and go into the the metaverse and
just live
march lockstep i also wonder if if it's
true that we are living in some kind of
simulation maybe we're the people who
are actually in the pods and they
actually are npcs
you know oh the whole npc thing i
watched that show free guy the other day
that movie that's my son he was like we
should watch this
uh because i was telling him
that i thought um i was telling him that
i thought the whole npc concept was
really wild and uh and i was like what
if there's npcs in real life and he was
like
yeah i've been thinking about that we
should watch this movie and i'm like
you're 11.
you came up with this already yeah yeah
i think people can like go into mpc mode
and then snap back out of it and all of
a sudden they have sentience again
they're like oh my gosh what have i done
sometimes i'll even wake up and be like
wow what was i doing yesterday i was in
like a a weird fog yesterday and today i
don't know i had this weird thing during
covid where like it took me a little
while to realize that this was going on
but you know we were like locked down
and you couldn't go anywhere and
everything was closed and i started to
like just not want to move i just didn't
want to move at all and then i realized
like oh you have this weird idea that if
you just stop moving
this whole thing will be over sooner oh
we have a correction kyle billing says
the movie i was referring to was 2149 in
the aftermath and i remember now that's
that's i'm going to write that down yeah
that's it sounds basically like what you
talked about yeah was poisonous and he
was in a pot or whatever 2149 the
aftermath yeah you know you know movies
also cool totally totally irrelevant is
time trap i don't know that that movie's
great cool name yeah you think people
are in such a state of panic right now
that they're just kind of like head down
wait for this all to end wait for the
whole
war and iraq to end wait for the coven
to end wave shot all the pain
all the things i'm afraid of yeah wait
for the alien invasion that hasn't been
false flagged on us yet to end well we
really want things to end
like as a culture it seems like i don't
really some people no i don't want
things to end either but like i feel
like our culture is really gearing up
for just being like and that's it we
burned ourselves out that's it enough
gravity gravity hurts let's end it was
it i think sheamus came up with the joke
we're talking about what the future
would be like and he was like wouldn't
it be funny if it's like 200 years in
the future and everything's just the
same and some guy like gets in a time
machine and goes to the future and he
comes out and everything looks normal
like it was when he left and he's like
he asked someone what year it was and
they're like oh it's 22 22 and he's like
but everything's the same and they're
like that was it like that was that was
all our ideas we ran out that was it
nothing else after that we kind of just
you know just
there's a bunch more mcdonald's but you
know other than that nothing real
beyond the kiosk right it's like a mic
judge movie
for sure they've talked about the end of
the world for the millennials since the
beginning of humanity someone's out
there like it's all coming to an end
this is it constantly obsessed with the
end there's this play i think it's
called american dream
maybe it's not but it's uh by this
playwright len jenkin who's this
new york playwright and at the end of
this sort of wild romp
all of these characters just start
saying i don't care about
philosophy just tell me how it ends
i don't care about philosophy i gotta i
gotta manage i'm at the point where i'm
like
i feel like we've reached this
a certain number of seasons of humanity
to where they're doing reruns
you know kind of sucks yeah it's just a
repeat and then it's just like okay
it's like it's like watching i saw the
batman
like this past weekend they call it the
batman that's like what the movie is
called the batman but the batman is like
a common thing yeah been around like
that that phrase has been around for a
long time
uh yeah there's like cartoons there's a
cartoon called the batman there's comics
the batman but uh uh that wouldn't have
any super powers it would be batman's
because he's just rich
actually his superpower is defined as
peak human because he's trained on the
mountaintops and he's master of like
ninjitsu and he's also rich i would just
really go with the once we get the rich
part i'd be okay yeah but i i i digress
that was a movie where i was you know it
starts off like pretty good and then
slowly gets worse but never ends
it just doesn't stop
it's like we've caught the bad guy and
i'm like well it's finally over and
there's an act four and i'm like okay
and then they introduce a whole bunch of
random plot elements and i'm like okay
at this point and i and i feel like that
was a great that movie was a great way
to understand life in the past decade
oh you think it's over and it just keeps
going yeah
yeah but no but but but more and more
absurd yeah like you know we went from
we've got a pandemic
with then we got a pandemic started get
this let's let's recount the past couple
of years a pandemic starts
all right
everyone's like we're shutting down the
president who's donald trump by the way
gets on tv and says we're going to be
banning travel with europe and we're and
i'm sitting there with my friends and
we're like whoa it's getting serious and
then two months later the biggest riots
we've seen in five decades billions of
dollars in damage 30 plus dead and i'm
like
is it a pandemic happening and then
we're like
back to the pandemic and then i'm like
okay that didn't end now we're now that
then intermittent in all of that is like
escalation of civil war people being
killed in the streets and it's like man
the more we see this stuff and more it
feels like the country is going to
collapse and then all of a sudden world
war iii starts right it's just like okay
it really feels like someone you know
and you have the new president just go
go ahead i'm sorry oh i know the
president's joe biden now
it's like we thought it was funny that
donald trump was the president because
he's like a tv reality star and now we
have joe biden who's who is
essentially a a a mr magoo yeah like he
is this is
he also he sits up there he hardly says
he like looks at you with his little
slinty eyes and then he whispers you
know kind of yells it's not gonna be
world war three we're not sending troops
into ukraine have you guys seen the
south park episode where it turns out
earth is a reality show okay and the
aliens are just like we we're we're done
with the show so we're gonna blow the
earth up it's like it's you know 3 000
seasons and we're just done that's a fun
thing in sci-fi where the earth is
actually just totally irrelevant and
they're gonna pave it over for a highway
like in hitchhikers and stuff yeah what
do you think is going to be the next
thing then when
normal
people get peaked into understanding
that they're being massively lied to
so i i don't i don't know if that will
happen neural nets happening
see i i so because of what i do and i
defend women's rights then i'm used to
the media peddling what i call lies uh
about really important
what are what are
factually live and and i'm i'm kind of
used to that i'm used to our politicians
going along with uh
telling absolute silly lies about
biological sex and what words mean
but then we had the pandemic in which
that sort of really
propelled more lies and narratives and
really obvious overt kind of dishonest
narratives and now we've got the war in
ukraine which
because of all these
these lies i think people are finding it
really difficult to believe anything
that's being told by the mainstream
media
uh and so where where the hell next well
on thursday i don't know if you saw this
the white house invited uh 30 tick tock
stars to give them the propagandist
lines about the war in ukraine is that
like when they peddled the holy bee
oh my goodness yeah so they you know
what what could be next what could be
next i think actually we have a lot of
stuff going on with the
voting rights i wonder if that could be
part of it like the
there's like oh i don't know who's gonna
get into all that
well that's a mess i don't think that's
big enough like yeah you know kovid was
huge it engulfed everyone black lives
matter was huge it engulfed everyone now
world war three or whatever battle and
gulf everyone yeah so that will be the
third thing right that was my first
thought was aliens but i think it's too
obvious now i think it's too obvious
like that's just not going to be the
plot point because we don't have talking
plasma it's just obvious obviously yeah
but not
it feels like
you know
we live in a reality where someone is
trying to keep people entertained you
know and it's just like okay regular
human human civilization wasn't working
the elite are trying to keep the plebs
entertained or or
it's you know in 2016 the large hadron
collider fired up for the first time is
that what happened right before trump
got elected that was wild now we're just
in this crazy multiverse of madness
doctor strange has you know that's
interesting
oh my goodness like dolly the sheep in
the uk
that that didn't go well well i think
there's like 10 different bidens there's
all just different kinds of problems
probably the difference
is going to keep ramping up right
probably the war is going to keep
ramping up the ukraine thing i think i
think i think we are headed towards hot
war between nato and russia for sure
yeah i think that that's that's what
we're looking at well so let me
let me give you guys a direct reference
i don't know if actually i'm pretty sure
i pulled it up
but uh uh maybe we can send the tick
tocks here we go yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there